no foreign Ministers of the G7 will
conclude talks today which have been
taking place in Germany Ukraine was top
of the agenda with diplomats pledging to
provide more military aid in what they
called a powerful sign of unity uh the
co-founder of the council onto your
strategy James Rogers joins us now James
very good morning to you
um I wonder what you may have made
um of the what seems like pending move
by both Sweden and Finland to get into
NATO what what is your assessment of how
much that shakes the Kaleidoscope so to
speak
yeah good morning to be with you um this
is quite a significant move because of
course Finland and Sweden remained
primarily neutral during the Cold War
and although they moved closer towards
NATO and of course with their membership
of the European Union uh the Western
position uh during the aftermath of the
Cold War uh they're now seeking direct
uh NATO membership the uh president and
prime minister of Finland issued a
statement uh two days ago and then
Sweden issued a report yesterday which
confirmed that they see the
deterioration of the European strategic
situation they believe that Russia is an
increasingly unpredictable State even
more unpredictable than the Soviet Union
was and that this requires them both to
move towards membership of NATO and of
course a couple of days before that uh
Boris Johnson visited both capitals to
issue security assurances to both um
both countries
so what then do we make of a potential
opposition coming from from Turkey I
mean do they have do they have the
casting votes and all of this how much
weight does everyone really have in in
capitals like Washington London so on
well it requires unanimity for a new
member to join uh the alliance so turkey
could cause
um problems however some analysts
believe that it's more a case that
turkey might be seeking some kind of
concessions rather than seeking to block
them uh outright and of course countries
like the US and the UK which provide the
Mainstay of the resources and strategic
wherewithal of the alliance have some uh
say over uh the ultimate Direction shall
we say but it could cause some
diplomatic uh wrangling in order to uh
replicate the Turks and allow both
Sweden and Finland in
we had an interview we've been carrying
on the channel an interview with our
interface between our International
Affairs editor and uh the head of
Defense intelligence for Ukraine a
couple of I I raising kind of lines
coming out of that first of course that
there could be an end in sight to the
war of the second that there is
potentially a coup building in Moscow I
mean how much validity should we give to
those in the absence of any further
Evidence
I think that's difficult to say I mean I
think the Russian objective has changed
of course initially it was to seize Kiev
in a sort of lightning strike that
failed and then the Russians tried to
use heavy armor to surround and circle
and then uh seize the city that also
fails so now they are moving
increasingly to operations uh in the
east of Ukraine where they already have
um a degree of influence now the
Russians have always uh sought I think
over the last let's say eight years
since they invaded Ukraine back in 2014
uh to engage in what's called non-linear
Warfare that is to say to uh actually
provoke and promote conflict in the
country in order to drag it down and to
prevent it from moving towards both NATO
and the European Union which of course
is what Ukraine has been seeking uh to
do so there might be an objective here
within Russia to actually just prolong
the conflict Without End in order to to
prevent Ukraine from consolidating and
joining uh joining the West now on the
terms of uh a coup in in in in Moscow uh
that is a possibility but at this stage
I think it is very unlikely uh the uh
Putin regime has some degree of control
over the country uh and has built that
up over the last uh 20 odd years but
nonetheless it is true that the the
regime's war in Ukraine has failed
miserably so far and that's becoming
increasingly apparent to the Russian
people it is no longer a special
military operation as the Kremlin calls
it but it has become increasingly an
outright war and a war as we've seen
with some pretty horrendous uh
consequences and and actions undertaken
by the Russians and I think this despite
the regime's control over the media
space has become increasingly apparent
to the Russian people uh as well as of
course the Russian political and
economic Elites and in that context uh
you know a coup in the long run or a
regime change within the country cannot
be entirely I think ruled out how then
is this information getting to to the
Russian public given the strangle that
they have on the media given that the
controls that they Place uh on the
internet and and elsewhere I mean this
week of course it was victory victory
Day parade and lots of Russian eyes will
have been on that but it was a it was a
drastically reduced Victory Day Parade
by my Reckoning
yeah uh I think it primarily through
word of mouth and information that's
seeping through from uh the soldiers
that have been uh sent to Ukraine to
fight getting back to their families uh
and other forms of of information
exchange like that uh of course as
you'll rightly point out that the the
regime does continue to have a strong
hold over the information that the
Russian people uh are able to access
great job you on the program this
morning thanks very much for joining us
thank you